el silencioso daño psicológico otra de
las heridas abiertas de miles de
libaneses tras la devastadora explosión
en el puerto de beirut a principios de
mes que destruyó buena parte de la
capital pesadillas ansiedad miedo es el
trauma de más de 600.000 menores después
de la dolorosa experiencia que tiene y
escuché un sonido muy fuerte me tape los
oídos y me escondí bajo el lavamanos
anoche estaba dormida y mi hermano
estaba jugando con un recipiente de
plástico me asustó el sonido y me
desperté papá tuvo que leerme el corán
para ayudarme a dormir
después de limpiar su apartamento de
escombros y cristales rotos esta joven
se unió a un grupo de vecinos para
distribuir alimentos a las víctimas
trabajar duro le ayuda a dormir y la
distrae de lidiar con las secuelas del
estallido que mató a más de 180 personas
y dejó a otros 300.000 sin hogar
otra meta es traer hija todos estamos
muy traumatizados pero todos pensamos
que no es el momento de relajarnos y no
estoy segura de que esta sea una manera
correcta de tratar el trauma es correcto
llengües líbano un país endurecido por
guerras pasadas y conflictos sectarios
ya estaba sumido en una profunda crisis
económica política y social antes de la
catástrofe que empeoró la salud mental
de los libaneses pero donde todavía rige
un fuerte estigma hacia las enfermedades
mentales
los libaneses han tenido muchas
conmoción es especialmente este año una
asociación de conmociones y esto impacta
nuestra resistencia y hace difícil que
la gente se recupere como antes
ante el aumento de llamadas los
psicólogos advierten de la necesidad de
brindar atención especializada para
ayudar a los libaneses a lidiar con las
y el estrés agudo de unos ciudadanos
acostumbrados a la resiliencia